[Music]
your co-star Kristen Bell yeah was here
not too long ago sorry I'm sure she
didn't behavior so now well you know
everybody loves Kristen Bell and I know
you do you guys like to give each other
a hard time but I know that you're very
close but since frozen came out which
has become such a smash hit has it gone
to her head for sure yeah oh yeah that's
all she would talk about she'd show up
in the mornings and go oh not you know
just saying bye see the numbers this
weekend
oh we were number one again I was like
yeah like you're the only one who's ever
been in a you know number one movie you
know get in line incredibly sexy woman
yeah yeah and her soul she's a fatty
you've explained that to her yeah what's
what's your relationship like on the set
cuz you know I know you guys like to
give each other a hard time it's the
same on the set really I mean no it's it
we have a lot of fun on the state it's a
really great you've probably met all the
people that work in on the show and
everyone's great and the crew is great
and we just have a great time I mean
where else could you be on a show and
call your lead actress Patti all day
long and she loves it right right yeah
I'll fire her ass